Let's go next to Patrick from Vernon Hills,
Patrick from Vernon Hills. You're on the air.
Hey, David. How's it going? It's going
well. I guess I have a question about.
Camp where we go forward with our media ecosystem,
I read a book recently that looked at the
historical effects of networks in
society specifically a good parallel was
when the printing press was created and then
Christianity shattered into a thousand pieces. And
we had decades of war after that
because everybody could read their own
interpretation of the Bible and have it
all coming through the Catholic Church
and feels now like the media has been shattered
into a thousand pieces and we all just get
wherever we want. And, you know, talking to
conservatives, they know even they haven't
read the same stories I've read. And we're
just operating from a completely different
set of information. And we can't even
talk about ideas. We're just talking about
what's true and what's not true.
You know, I love that you're bringing
this up. I love that you're bringing this up.
Because, you know, one of the things there was a
very interesting discussion on The David Pakman
Show sub Reddit recently where someone posted
they did it in sort of an attack way, but I
still appreciated it. They said, you know,
listening to The David Pakman Show, watching
The David Pakman Show alone is not going to make
you informed or educated or smart or whatever.
And they meant it, I think is an attack. But I
don't see I agree with that. And one of the things
that I have been talking about for a long time is
my my hope with this show is not that people end
up believing all the same things that I believe.
And my hope is not that I become the sole source
of commentary for people. What I hope to do with
this show is to be part of the commentary diet
and hopefully expose people to the importance
of reading economics and reading history
and reading sociology and philosophy.
And one of the real concerns with a lot of this
right wing drivel that's out there is the same
thing we heard from Trump, which was only I can
fix it. Only I tell you the truth, you're not
being told the truth here or there. And this is
fake news and that's fake. And all of this stuff,
what you're pointing out is maybe I don't know
if you're deliberately pointing this out or not,
but I'm going to pretend you are because it's such
a great point. It's really important for us to be
consuming lots of writing that has sort of stood
the test of time, ideas and books that are still
being read decades after they've been written,
sometimes centuries after they've been written
a really long time. And Nassim Nassim Taleb in The
Black Swan and A. Antifragile writes about this.
You really want to be starting with your base
and that should be, you know, really reading
texts of history, economics, philosophy,
etc.. Then on top of that, you place news,
actual news reporting that's going on. And the
top of the pyramid pyramid should be shows like
mine where I'm not giving you an opinion on
an empty platform. Hopefully you are coming
in with the base of the pyramid and I'm just
giving you my thoughts. And we all are sharing
a lot of this information. Now, unfortunately,
as you're pointing out, a lot of people come
in and just listen to opinion shows and don't
know history, economics, philosophy, science,
etc. That's a problem. But but I'm I'm off on
a rampage. But you're making a beautiful point.
Yeah, I think that's not quite what
I was getting at, but pretty close.
I like your hierarchy of knowledge that you
laid out there, right? I'm just in every area.
I'm just concerned that, you know,
people aren't doing that. And they
are. Yes. Really getting their information
from the top of the pyramid up at their base.
That's you know, your assessment is correct.
That's what's happening. And it's horrible.
I can't talk to people because I'm just we
don't even have a common set of facts to talk
about. And it's so frustrating. Right. Talking
about is this true or is this not true? I like
climate change. I'm you know, climate change is
real. What do we do about it? We're stuck on.
Is climate change real? Yeah. Interesting question
is all we do about it. There's a lot of good wait.
There's thousands of ways to solve the problem.
But like Alcoholics Anonymous, you know, the first
step is admitting you have a problem. You can't
do anything until you get past that first step.
Absolutely. Yeah. I'm reading Merchants of
Doubt now about the industry of denying that
tobacco smoke is harmful to health, denying that
acid rain is bad, denying that there's climate
change and there's entire industries based around
furthering doubt about that. And so it's not
part of it is uneducated people, but also part
of it is very well funded industries that want
people to doubt the facts.
Yep. All right. Thank you
so much. I love your show.
All right. Thank you. Great,
great call. Appreciate it. Very, very
important things being brought up.